the design of this shoe starts in Oregon
in 1981 and with a man called Tinker
Hatfield he was an architect for Nike
hired to drop offices and showrooms on
the company's campus after making a
statement on the outside of the building
he was asked to join the designers on
the inside in a race to develop sneakers
a former NASA engineer had recently
introduced the idea of scaling air
bubbles in the soles for extra comfort
and performance but competition was
fierce and Nike still needed an edge
Hatfield headed to Paris in search of
inspiration while he was there he
visited the Pompidou Center a radical
building famous for its inside out
design which exposed the building's
components like escalators and heating
pipes for everyone to see Hatfield
decided to apply the same principle to
his own design revealing the inner
workings of his shoe by making the air
cushioning system visible the marketing
team thought the air bubble would seem
like a weakness but the Nike Air Max one
was an instant hit when it launched in
1987 originally pairs sold for $75 now
they go for double that today Tinker
Hatfield is one of the most successful
shoe designers in the world he even
created those legendary self-lacing
sneakers back to the future fame stylish
and innovative this is the design that
stayed one step ahead simply by being
turned inside out
you